Speaker 1: Let's go next to Vince from
Wisconsin. Vince, you're on the air.
Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, great.
How are you doing, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thanks, Vince.
Speaker 2: As I just had two questions, I
had a brief question and a longer question.
All right. My longer question is
what are your thoughts on Attorney
General Merrick Garland performance so far?
Speaker 1: I don't know that he's done enough
one way or the other to really evaluate his
performance. He has put out some memos, memoranda,
as we might call them, saying that he is going
to be looking into this or exploring that. I just
don't think we have enough data points. I mean,
he's been in in his job months, and I don't know
that I have anything substantive to say about
his performance this way at this point in time.
Speaker 2: He seems pretty milquetoast to me.
I mean, he's he's not. He's refused to be still
sitting on charges for obstruction
of justice charges. The charge is
representing him for God's sake in that lawsuit,
leaflets and carols, and he was accused of rape.
Yeah, and a defamation lawsuit.
Speaker 1: I mean, that's going
forward as far as I know.
Speaker 2: Oh, really? Yeah,
that's good.
Speaker 1: Are
you rolling dice in the background, by the way?
Speaker 2: Oh, no, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, go ahead.
No, not right now, OK, cool. So sorry about
the noise, but my question is are would you
consider interviewing Brian Tyler Cohen?
Speaker 1: Um, I mean, I don't know
that it's for our show. Usually, we don't
interview people who just have like other
channels like mine, but I would definitely
do a collaboration with him of some kind,
like on a live stream. I think it'd be a better
fit for that. But like on our show, you know,
I don't tend to interview like Sam Seder or Farron
Cousins or that type of thing on the podcast, but
I would do a collaboration with them, for sure.
Speaker 2: OK. All right, thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right, my pleasure. Thanks
for the call. Very much. Appreciate it.